it's been four months since the
inconclusive election in July left Pedro
Sanchez's hopes of a second term as
prime minister hanging by a thread but
after weeks of Coalition talks Sanchez
narrowly secured the majority needed
supported by several smaller left-wing
parties as well as Catalan
separatists it's been a fraud process
day and night for the past two weeks
thousands of of conservative and
right-wing demonstrators have staged
angry protests Furious that in return
for the support of the Catalan parties
Sanchez is granting amnesty to hundreds
of figures involved in Catalonia's
failed bid for Independence in
2017 Sanchez says amnesty will heal the
wounds opinion polls suggest that the
majority of Spaniards do not
agree it is a complete mockery a mockery
because they are betraying all the
Spanish people bying making a P with
criminals it seems to me to be a Swindle
it is a robbery what's happening is
against the Constitution it is against
the
law prime minister Sanchez's wayfer thin
majority means his position is far from
secure the leftwing and Regional parties
who voted him back into office all have
radically different
ideologies and the Catalan parties still
Harbor Ambitions of another Independence
referendum Paul Brennan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer